so this one plate looks Systema it's
gotta be a song about be sure you have
to mix a couple all the best nap girl in
all of Hollywood okay not know you do it
no no delicate hands to some other
doorbell hope you're a regular person
well I guess who are you
hi yes yes we are here to invite you to
AAA part yes and in acapella Graham I'm
acapella Graham okay it's time to
celebrate
we know that it's early but we can't
wait for Christmas I'm so excited we
mighty Oh having a pool party for pitch
perfect 3 it's Christmas in the
summertime if that is the thing Oh
bubbles okay
no I don't I'm actually afraid of
bubbles um that was so creative I'm
really sweet the thing is I have no idea
who you are
oh you're gonna tell me Vicky I'm Carol
I am 1 million miles away we promise
we're enough sorry just throwing up our
day oh okay oh that one got my eye all
right it does feel a little stalkery um
the thing is I'm so busy
oh I'll get you a limo we'll go too late
and I love boarded up ROI I'm not I do
hate what okay the soap is this like if
I don't say yes you're never gonna leave
[Music]
all right let's go
where's the bowl don't face this anyway
I've got my bike and you can immerse
tight I promise you there's a limo
there's so mo so juicy with your picture
we sure do the acapella grunting for a
living we're doing that okay where's the
limo
[Music]